[Music]
we are empathetic creatures
yes
now some people see that as a weakness
but i decided long ago that i will say
how i feel
and if that does not conform to the
president's message so be it if that
gets me banned off air force one i will
fly commercial
as we say goodbye to summer we enter one
of our favorite times of year here at
rotten tomatoes and you all know what
time that is award season and just like
every year whether they're long time
favorites or the new kids on the block
there's gonna be cutthroat debate on who
did and who didn't make the tv academy's
list what are you gonna do
what are you gonna fight for
that's why for this list we wanted to
look at all the tv series for this year
that just couldn't manage to make the
cut so get ready to throw down as we
count down our list of the 2022 tv
series the emmy's snub
[Applause]
[Music]
number 10 black-ish
since its premiere in september of 2014
blackish has garnered critical acclaim
with anthony anderson and tracee ellis
ross having a combined tally of 12 emmy
nominations for outstanding lead actor
and actress in a comedy series after a
largely successful eight-year run and
the cancellation of its prequel spin-off
mix dish that premiered in 2019 blackish
in its eighth and final season only
managed to receive a couple of nods in
the categories of contemporary
hairstyling and contemporary costumes
starring anthony anderson tracy ellis
ross yaro shahidi and created by kenya
barris critics say although it seems
uncertain of its target audience
blackish ingratiates with a diverse cast
and engaging cultural issues we found
something way better than food we found
each other oh
now i know who's been watching all those
white girl movies on netflix
let's try something
all right they say the most
vulnerable and intimate thing you can do
is look into someone's eyes
without looking away son
waiting and exhaling is for the two of
you not for me hey pops
oh that's what i thought i thought the
same thing before it brought us together
all right and now i've never felt so
free
so come on pops let's do it come on man
look at me
do you see me pops
oh hell no i do not like this
nope
number nine this is us
a regular favorite at the emmys the nbc
drama this is us has won numerous awards
and nominations over the course of its
five season run picking up nominations
for outstanding drama series for four of
those five seasons many of the series
stars have received noteworthy acclaim
at the emmys as well including gerald
mccraney sterling k brown and ron cephas
jones but the academy seemed to forget
about this hugely popular tearjerker for
its sixth and final season receiving
only one nomination for outstanding
original music and lyrics despite a
widely recognized fan favorite
performance from mandy moore starring
milo ventimiglia mandy moore sterling k
brown and created by dan fogelman
critics say featuring full tilt
heartstring tugging family drama this is
us will provide a suitable surrogate for
those who have felt void in their lives
since parenthood went off the air
so are you
you know dating
am i dating have you been dating well uh
you know a little bit i guess i was in a
relationship last year that i thought
maybe had potential but uh
fizzled out sort of
a pattern these days um
all my days actually
i i focus on my kids you know i focus on
my kids and the non-profit because
i
i think i have this series of
failing at dating i just i can't find
the right um my
my
name
you cold
yeah
okay
[Music]
number eight maid
with an already impressive run in the
winter awards circuit after this limited
series premiered in 2021 with
nominations from the golden globes and
sag made was a shoe-in to turn some
heads at the 2022 emmy awards however
despite largely positive reviews for the
heart-wrenching limited series and
nominations for outstanding directing
and outstanding writing for a limited
series it missed the big kahuna being
left out of the running for outstanding
limited series a major consolation
though was margaret quali's nomination
for outstanding lead actress in a
limited series who stars alongside her
real-life mother starring margaret quali
nick robinson anika noni rose and
created by molly smith metzler critics
say maid takes great care with its
sensitive subject matter to craft a
drama that is not always easy to watch
but undeniably powerful grounded by an
outstanding performance by margaret
quali so you're on parole
um no
got any priors
no don't lie i'm gonna check you got a
problem with background check
no
we paid that
no exceptions bump you up 50 cents once
the background check clears and you go
full-time
full-time great yes but full-time in a
40-hour week company policy is you can't
work more than six hours a day breaks my
heart it really does but i can't be
paying benefits
so it's capped
six hours a day max
okay
and tourist season's over so i really
only have one shift open it's a weekly
three-hour clean over on fisher island
one shift okay
so uniforms 25 bucks
comes out of your first check
number seven russian doll
netflix's comedy series russian doll was
an absolute bombshell during awards
season when it premiered back in 2019
picking up a total of 13 nominations
including outstanding comedy series and
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series for natasha leone who also
co-created the show but an even more
cerebral second season seemed to leave
the academy unimpressed with only a
single nomination for outstanding
cinematography although a three-year
hiatus between its first and second
season likely cost the siri some
momentum you would think giving birth to
yourself on a subway platform would
receive some recognition starring
charlie barnett greta lee and natasha
leon who also created the show with amy
poehler and leslie hedland critics say
russian doll may be stuck in a time loop
but this endlessly inventive series
never repeats itself as it teeters on a
seesaw shifting tones from fatally funny
to mournfully sad that is balanced with
exhilarating moxie by an astonishing
natasha liam nadia don't mess this up
maybe we're just supposed to like enjoy
the ride i'm still exploring my options
there are things in life that cannot be
explained
inexplicable things happening is my
entire modus operandi
where are we more like when are we
oh
never mind
[Music]
[Music]
yo
you're a time traveler
i prefer the term time prisoner
number six
insecure
with a widely loved four season run issa
rae's original comedy series insecure
aired its fifth and final season on hbo
last fall and fans were hopeful it could
finally bring home an outstanding comedy
series win but with a very crowded
comedy category filled with heavy
hitters like ted lasso barry and what we
do in the shadows it was a tall order
and insecure couldn't manage to get the
nomination still issa rae did get a nod
with her third overall nomination for
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series starring yvonne orgy natasha
rothwell and issa rae who also created
the show with larry wilmore critics say
isa's future remains uncertain but
insecure enters its final season a fully
confident comedy with plenty left to say
about friendship love and self-esteem i
told you i loved you and
we didn't even discuss it
were you just never gonna acknowledge
that
are you serious right now
you always trying to call me out for
something
cause you're always avoiding something i
mean you said that you might leave l.a
and
i'm not supposed to have a reaction to
that oh
all right so now that it's all about you
you're not even gonna ask me what i'm
going through
i am it's just
it feels like i made a choice
to commit to this and
it sounds like you're not
this is dumb you know how i feel about
you then why are you being so defensive
cause you telling me that i'm not
committed you're the one that's been uh
inconsistent
what does that mean it means you crying
in my mouth one minute then telling me
that you won't be the next minute then
you want to take things slow now you're
telling me you love me
what do you want from me
you all over the place
you know what let's just drop it
number five atlanta
following a grueling four-year hiatus
donald glover's comedy series atlanta
returned for its much anticipated third
season but after the acclaim that its
first two seasons garnered which
included nominations for outstanding
comedy series both years atlanta's third
season received some divided reviews
among fans with the series taking a
change of pace outside of its central
four characters and although donald
glover gets yet another nod for
outstanding lead actor in a comedy
series this ultimately may have led to
the series failing to receive a
nomination this year for the first time
in its run starring bryan tyree henry
lakeith stanfield zazi beatz and donald
glover who also created the show critics
say atlanta takes paperboy and his
entourage out of georgia but this
inspired third season proves that the
more things change the more they stay
weird she's like
all lives matter that's the problem
i'm not okay
i don't know how you're okay
oh wait i mean it didn't go down like
that
i'm fine
it was not that big a deal why is she
crying
okay where is she
i mean i've never met this girl but
she's definitely
i just want to meet my fiance that's her
man are you coming back in here for
being all racists
you're just a bloody fashion
number four pen 15.
when the second season of this quirky
comedy premiered back in 2021 it
received top honors from the academy
with nominations for outstanding comedy
series and although the last half of its
second season has received high praise
from critics and fans alike maya erskine
and anna conkle's pen 15 received nada
zero zilch not managing to receive a nod
in a single category for this awards
season's nomination starring maya
erskine and anna konkel who both created
the show with sam zebelman critics say
an excellent showcase for maya erskine
anna conkle and their well-cast
classmates penn 15 sophomore season goes
deeper into the nuances of middle school
life without losing any of its cringy
charm there were these boys in our grade
who were not kind to like i need you to
beat them up yeah
like it just needs to happen why should
i
see like i told you he wouldn't care
this is literally like the worst day of
my life and you'll probably call me you
just too
did you just say you just
eugene is the worst thing you can be
called the list of you just has passed
they're all heinous dogs
there's a list
look i'm not gonna beat up a seventh
grader but i can teach you some words
um what do they look like
um
well
like um
bran he like has this like chestnut
silky hair and it's like he has brown
honeydew no what are his bad features
oh
number three better things
life isn't always kind and that's okay
something pamela adlon's character sam
fox from better things knows all too
well and the academy has definitely not
been kind to adlon's comedy series after
a phenomenal five seasons following the
story of a single mother plus working
actor trying to raise three daughters
avalon has been praised with creating
and portraying one of the strongest
female characters on television even
with a critically acclaimed final season
better things couldn't seem to get the
attention of the academy as it was once
again ignored failing to get any nods
for any category starring celia emery
mikey madison and pamela adlon who also
created the show with louis ck critics
say bittersweet funny as ever and
brimming with wisdom better things final
send-off is as good as it gets how's
your day going so far
just a minute
can i help you
i have uh nine o'clock with dr babu sam
fox okay
sam
fox
mm-hmm
there you go
feel that out sit down okay but i just
wanted to check on the follow-up
appointment dr babu wanted me to make
it's on the 26th mm-hmm it's on the 29th
we moved it oh
mm-hmm we tried to leave you several
voicemails your inbox was always full
you need to clean that out oh no you see
i can't because i have all my daughter's
voicemails saved from when there were
babies i just i can't delete them you
understand
right
number two reservation dogs
premiering in august of 2021 taikawa
tt's and sterling harjo's comedy drama
series reservation dogs has enjoyed a
raving reception following a group of
indigenous american teenagers and
produced by a predominantly indigenous
crew the series has been recognized as a
gem for both fans and critics teething
with emotions and laughs while
reservation dogs has received nods from
the golden globes and the peabody awards
the academy of television arts and
sciences remain unimpressed snubbing the
series entirely with zero nominations in
zero categories starring de ferra
lunatai devery jacobs paulina alexis and
created by sterling harjo and
taikawatiti critics say aimless
afternoons yield absurd delights in
reservation dogs a loki comedy that
definitely captures the malaise of youth
and res life thanks in no small part to
its impressive central crew
are y'all more spirits no man it's
mozambico we got the same uncle
i'm gonna go get those kids back kind of
gangers both red and blue indian mafia
couldn't make up their minds if they
want to be bloods or crypts more maybe
they're blips or maybe they're cruds
why not just wear purple who are they
why are they in the village oh they're
new the founders auntie just move over
there by keith's house and she's fine
too yeah and they all cousins i guess
some chick named jackie with blonde hair
was the leader of a gang in the city i
heard about the big jackets and when she
moved here they initiated her cousin
they probably killed some people and
they been looking for y'all why are they
looking for us cause they heard y'all
with a reservation bandits who told them
that
that's my bad see
i kind of told them y'all was the
toughest in town and they asked me what
your gang name was and that's all i
could think of man why would you tell
them we're in a gang bro always wanted
to be in a gang i guess they trying to
take you off the throne now take you out
the power wow
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
we crashed
following the true story of the dramatic
rise and fall of wework and its founder
adam newman we crash struggled to find
its footing with a wider audience and
couldn't muster a nomination for
outstanding limited series despite a
commanding performance from series star
jared leto what might be even more
surprising was a snub of letto's co-star
anne hathaway who has been celebrated by
critics with delivering a standout
performance in an already illustrious
career with her portrayal of a complex
and powerful figure within popular
culture starring jared leto anne
hathaway kyle marvin and created by drew
cravello and lee eisenberg critics say
the pacing can be frustrating but we
crash still works thanks to its
compelling central relationship and anne
hathaway's knockout performance i
thought that's it that's my thing that's
your thing you have a thing
you're home
it's just it can't be nothing again it
just can't be nothing again
it'll never be nothing
i didn't want to tell you this but i saw
him in line at popeyes once okay
you're bigger than this
[Music]
you're a leader
you're a teacher an artist a phenomenal
talent
there's so many more things to explore
in life
you're on a journey and you'll find it
do you really think that
[Music]
no
i believe it
[Music]
yellowstone
[Music]
this western family drama from paramount
took its time to settle in and find its
audience but impressive performances
from lead stars kevin costner and kelly
riley have amassed a strong fan base
just when it seemed as if award
recognition was on the horizon after a
sag nomination for its ensemble cast
yellowstone was completely ignored from
the emmy shortlist missing out on an
outstanding drama series nomination
starring and created by kevin costner
wes bentley kelly riley luke grimes and
cole hauser critics say yellowstone
proves too melodramatic to be taken
seriously diminishing the effects of the
talented cast and beautiful backdrops
see i know you think that it just
magically appears a jamba juice but
no grass grows in the ground
get her
summer's a vegan would you make her
something with no meat or eggs or milk
or milk or butter
or butter
maybe some pancakes i don't eat gluten
what's
gluten
so wait
you'll eat the wheat grass
but you won't eat the seed
our bodies aren't designed to digest it
who told you that doctors my doctor
never told me that well you should get a
new doctor you should get tested for
chlamydia you hippie okay beth
that's it
all right she's my guest you'll treat
her with respect or you leave
i got a meeting anyway
love you daddy
i hope you find a therapist who can help
you i hope you die of ass cancer
gaslit
when you combine the prowess of two
oscar-winning actors and julia roberts
and sean penn and put them together in a
historical drama series there's no doubt
that you have the right formula for an
award-winning machine right but it
wasn't written in the cards for gaslit a
modern take on the 1970s political
watergate scandal even with its
star-studded casts and superb
performances the series achieved only
three nominations for cinematography
sound mixing and editing with both julia
roberts and sean penn being overlooked
starring julia roberts sean penn dan
stevens and created by robbie pickering
critics say fronted by a nervy julia
roberts gaslight is less a slow burn
than an acting extravaganza of big
personalities enmeshed in historic
scandal you're lucky that uh your friend
was here to help you
no please you need to help me
the situation is not as it appears
i know all about your situation there's
nothing to be embarrassed about a lot of
women your age suffer from paranoid
episodes no no no you don't understand
i'm being held against my will they've
cut the cord on my phone
maybe a little time away from your
telephone would do you good mrs mitchell
maybe that's just what you need right
now
yes
that's right thank you
could you uh
get me a glass of water before you go
oh absolutely
how is she her delusions will pass until
then be sure to keep an eye on her don't
worry i'll take good care
and finally number one pachinko
the korean series taking the television
world by storm no it's not squid game
the other one pachinko this
multi-generational drama of a korean
immigrant family and based off the book
of min jin li has been applauded by fans
and critics as one of the best series of
the year to hit the small screens
despite a massively successful premiere
and already being renewed for his second
season by popular demand pachinko was
shut out completely from the drama
category receiving only one nod from the
academy for outstanding main title
design causing an uproar amongst the
show's growing fan base starring ya
zhang yoon lee min ho minha kim and
created by sue hugh critics say
intricate yet intimate pachinko is a
sweeping epic that captures the arc of
history as well as the enduring bonds of
family
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the ron
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you